[Music]
i have a phrase my phrase is technology
fails until it succeeds the point is
what will you as an individual
choose to use as your technology
to avoid starving to death or freezing
to death economically
that's the question so the mobile way
was
software leaping off of the desktop and
out of the office and into the world
of the teenager and on a saturday
afternoon
and that's what made for a facebook or
an amazon
uh mobile you know or google or youtube
you know and laid the laid the framework
for entertainment and
communications now we're moving on the
virtual wave
you're seeing the virtualization of a
whole class of products and services
that previously were delivered uh by
human beings
you can zoom anywhere at the speed of
light and bend time and space
if i'm a salesperson i can take 40 sales
calls a week
if i want in 40 different cities but the
other profound part of it is
what you just did when we started our
call which is
you punch the record button and
you and i are having a meeting cross
country
and that's about to be shared with
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people
anywhere anytime
three years from now someone will be
able to go back in time
three years and be in the room with us
now
for the cost of electricity we're
watching the virtualization of
money so i can tell you that gold that i
have and
if this were a real nobel prize it would
be worth about twenty four thousand
dollars
and uh and that gold came from the
collision
of two enormous neutron stars and that
happened perhaps five billion years ago
in our region of the galaxy
and the neutron enrichment basically a
giant atom not a 56
neutron but 10 to the 56 neutrons or
something like that
coming together the shrapnel of which
produced the gold
uh and that we find now you're saying
we're only going to have
you know 21 million coins that are
subdivided into so many satoshi's or
what bitcoin
but i don't think there's going to be
another neutron star that
put it this way if another neutron star
collides near the earth we've got much
bigger problems in our monetary
situation but you know the fact is
that's much more scarce than
my friend down the street minds bitcoin
uh in other words how can we be so
certain
that it is it has this permanence and it
has this durability
and resilience that it makes it a true
store of money the way that these
neutron stars did for us
many billions of years ago
um the history of money is
is human beings looking for some for
some system
that they can use to store and trade
value both with
each other and with themselves over time
with some commodities they're really
easy to produce
the hardest commodity to produce
that also had the characteristics that
we wanted for money was gold
i mean because we needed it to be
durable and stable like it needs to
it needs to last a thousand years we
mine gold gold miners produce about two
percent more gold every year
that means that if i took all of all of
the money in the world and i bought gold
with it and i had 100
of the gold in the world 100 years from
now i would have 12 and a half percent
of the gold in the world
gold is centralized which means uh you
can hypothecate it and you can sell it
short
there's no way for you to be sure that
the bank that holds all your gold
didn't actually sell the gold twice
without telling you
uh because you can't reasonably withdraw
100 million dollars of gold and stored
underneath your mattress
but and so that means that uh gold has
always been plagued
uh by people issuing notes against the
gold without enough gold to cover it
if you look at something like bitcoin
bitcoin is audited every 10 minutes
by 10 000 nodes so it's very it's very
challenging and not impossible to lie
about it
those 100 million people can take
personal custody if they want
because it has no mass what's the
prevent
you know a really black swan event as
tele would say
from you know government just saying
you're this is now illegal
and any proceeds we want to know the
history of every single coin
a lot of people are working very hard to
come up with some reason
why they shouldn't trust a new thing
meanwhile it's quite clear
that 7.8 billion people on the planet
have a problem
everybody with money on earth is going
to lose half their wealth in the next 48
months
if they do nothing if you live if you're
one of the billion people in a
collapsing developed economy
you're going to lose everything if you
do nothing the solution
is a digital monetary network that
doesn't dissipate
energy that you can access where no one
can corrupt it and you can take personal
custody of your money
of your monetary energy the laws of
thermodynamics and the conservation of
energy
right what's at the core of bitcoin
is the laws of thermodynamics and the
conservation of energy
if i put a million
dollars of monetary energy into the
network in the year 2020
i can go forward 250 years or 50 years
or 10 years or whatever amount of time
frame you want and i will have the same
amount of monetary energy
scaled up perfectly linearly
you know for the economic growth without
any individual stealing at all if you
take the same amount of monetary energy
and you put it into the dollar you will
lose 99
of that energy it will be stolen from
you
by the central bank and the fractional
reserve bankers over the course of
100 years maybe over the course of 10 to
15 years
when you live in the universe you have
to subject yourself
to the laws of thermodynamics you don't
get to create
energy or destroy energy or create mass
or destroy
there's a conservation of this stuff you
can't leap a million gazillion miles
we don't have a world where you get to
leap a million miles an hour
and murder everybody and the guy next to
you doesn't
right you're both subject to the same
laws of thermodynamics
in that world but in the world of fiat
there's one
dude that can steal the life work
of a billion people in a minute
on a whim and there's another person
that can't so the significance of
bitcoin is
you can take a portion of monetary
energy
you can store it on a network that no
politician
no bank no counterparty can
seize from you against your will and
nobody can debase or inflate away
via some uh some political edict
which is not the case with any other
monetary system on earth what is the
purpose
of wealth to you
money is monetary energy
monetary energy is the apex of all
energies
wealth is just uh energy and you can
channel it however you want
and it ultimately gets channeled based
upon the values
of the people with the energy right or
listeners that ask me you know how can i
talk to people that have
so much power the ability to convert
energy
and do work in a very brief amount of
time those obviously you're not going to
construct a mercenary army i hope you
know with with some of your money but
not on my agenda it would be a bad
investment anyway and have more energy
you can have more money
but we're also living in the most
polarized you know discrepancy between
those that can apply energy for in the
shortest amount of time
and those that cannot um how do you does
that
affect you do you think about that if i
have 25 trillion dollars of currency
floating around
and i just print another trillion i just
seized four percent of all the power in
the civilization
and i just did it by fiat right by edict
without even a law being passed right so
so the biggest power discrepancy is is
the current
uh power to print money currency
and that leads to all the other power
discrepancies and if you want to reverse
that
then you need you need to educate the
world so that people understand that
they should switch
from the fiat standard to the bitcoin
standard because
if you're on the bitcoin standard nobody
could print more bitcoin
and deprive you of your monetary energy
the swimming pool won't work the
airplane won't fly the ship
won't sail the electrical system won't
work with the short circuit the
pneumatic
system won't work with a leak in it you
know nothing
works in the engineering world if you
don't have
you know integrity and a closed system
and nothing works in math if you just
change the number right i mean the point
is math is math so
if you want to reject all of math all of
thermodynamics all of science
the conservation of energy and the
universe then yeah
you can run your society based upon fiat
currency with one individual that makes
up however much money they want to make
up at any given time
but it seems pretty clear that the rest
of the universe doesn't work
that way what does it mean to talk about
the thermodynamics
of bitcoin or anything in particular
when it comes to computation or storage
of information
i'm going to give a quick overview of a
physicist view of such a
process and take you through an exercise
in the calculation of what
thermodynamics
really is all about which is entropy
entropy is a measure of disorder of
chaos of
ignorance of lack of information or
clutter in a system
and it's often talked about in computer
context and especially in the
application
of computers by michael saylor in the
video you just saw
in the context of how easy how simple
how thermodynamically
sound such currency is
and we're going to consider the most
basic process in computing which is the
act of forgetting
which is the act of erasing and the
question is when you erase information
how much energy is required to conduct
that process in a computer
how would you actually do it well you
can bound how much
uh would need to be done by considering
the changing of
every single bit of information stored
in a computer
uh in a byte of information in a
gigabyte of information
uh computers use uh in the context of
bitcoin they use
256 bits for encrypting
uh certain aspects of the ledger of the
blockchain
so i'm going to use the example of
looking at the erasing
of a of an amount of memory known as a
gigabyte
so a gigabyte is 1024 megabytes
a megabyte is 1024 kilobytes
and a kilobyte is 1024 bytes
now what is a byte a byte is eight bits
so that could be represented by
eight light bulbs uh where the light
bulbs could either be on or off
it could be represented in computer
memory by zeros and ones
zero volts five volts etc and so that's
how we
represent computers represent memory
first question is if your computer rates
and overwrites over all that
one gigabyte worth of memory and keeps
no record of the information
that was stored i want to ask the
question of how much
process what what how much in that
process how much
entropy is created second law of
thermodynamics that michael saylor
refers to
is always about this law that entropy
can never decrease
so entropy will be representing it
mathematically
in this short little conversation and
the question is once you have that much
entropy
and you've now dumped it into the larger
system of the room in which the computer
is sitting
how much heat how much thermal energy
is associated with that is it a large
amount of heat is it a small amount of
heat
and then you imagine how much uh memory
how many times is done every second
on the blockchain the question is how
much
energy does this actually take so
entropy if we regard
the calculation of entropy we note that
there are if there are n
bits uh which is a slot you can think of
as a slot or a placeholder and a
transistor
and each one can take on a value high or
low uh zero or one
then you actually have two states for
each for each bit
so you have two to the n possible
different states
so we can convert a gigabyte
into a megabyte and then a megabyte into
a kilobyte
etc and then eventually we convert the
number of bytes
into bits and then we've got 2 to the
10th times 2 to the 10th times 2 to the
10th times 2 to the third
and if you calculate that at home you
get 2 to the 33rd
power bits of information
so that is the total amount of bits
represented in one
gigabyte now it could either be in one
of two states a zero or one so that
means
if you have n bits that's two to the n
different states
that are possible in calculating the
total available amount of
of of entropy that means that the number
of states there are is 2 to the 2 to the
33rd
power it turns out that entropy usually
involves a calculation of very large
numbers
and so to simplify the large numbers we
realized since the time of boltzmann
that the entropy is most conveniently
expressed
in terms of a logarithm of the number of
states so the exact expression that
boltzmann has on his tombstone is that
it relates the amount of entropy times
his famous constant k
and we get an entropy of 8.2 times 10 to
the minus 14
joules per kelvin a joule is a
relatively small number too
but we said we're doing this this
calculation all the computers
that do operate on bitcoin they do it at
room temperature
and so the room temperature we'd
multiply by 300 and we still don't get a
very large number we're getting
something
that is going to be a very very
tiny amount in temperature uh of
additional temperature that's added to
the to the world or additional heat
rather that's added to the world
in terms of joules we get uh by
multiplying this increase in
entropy this 8 times 10 to the minus 14
joules per kelvin times room temperature
is about 300 kelvin
we get an almost infinitesimal or
microscopic
amount of energy which is equal to
the amount of of heat that will be
dumped into the environment
and we get an answer that's about 2.4
times
10 to the minus 11 joules now is that a
big number or is that a small number
turns out it's a small number but again
we only considered the multiplication of
these bits or changing of these bits
from zeros
to ones for one gigabyte worth of memory
in a computer at room temperature
so that's a small amount of energy
required for a gigabyte
but if you imagine terabytes which are
thousands of gigabytes or 10 or
thousands of thousands of terabytes uh
that could
be conceivable for a supercomputer farm
that's operating perhaps at a
bitcoin farm you could get many many
joules per second
or however often the bitcoin
the blockchain is up updated so it's it
could be that it is not insignificant
but i did want to
only illuminate from a physics point of
view where
are these operations coming into play
what is actually causing
the increase in energy or requiring
energy it's actually
a process related in thermodynamics to
the entropy
of both creation or storage of
information and
not destruction of information we
physicists don't believe that's possible
there is some trace of the of the
process that was used to erase
that could in principle be used in a
reversible process to recover the
information
but you could never recover that heat
that heat is lost forever
to the universe and can no longer be
recovered to do
anything useful such as writing new
information
or producing matter and anti-matter in
pairs for example
so it is a process and under which is
governed by
the laws of thermodynamics